I get asked about morning routines a lot
I've interviewed hundreds and hundreds
of top performers in various fields
about their morning routines and where
should you start this is one of the most
common questions and I'd recommend
starting off very very simply number one
when you go to bed put your phone on
airplane mode because if you wake up and
you're barrage with text messages and
notifications and so on
you will be immediately short-circuited
you want to have a boot up sequence of
your own and I do believe as I've been
told if you win the morning you win the
day so what are a few ingredients if
you're starting as a blank slate I would
recommend number one waking up making
your bed I know this sounds odd it was
first recommended to me by an Indian
monk he convinced me of the merits
because you are accomplishing one thing
at the beginning of the day no matter
what happens with unforeseen variables
for the rest of the day you will return
to a made bed at the end of the day and
as a bookmark beginning an end it sets
you up psychologically to be more
productive and also to feel better even
if things go sideways later in addition
to that if you work at home in
particular it's common that external
mess creates internal mess in terms of
mental state so making your bed does not
mean for seasons it just means in my
case pulling up the sheets and blanket
and so on so it looks like I haven't had
an elephant rolling around in my bed
it's really quite simple then arrange
the pillows in a semi pretty fashion
subjectively and there you have it what
I recommend for many people right after
that is just do 10 15 push-ups or some
type of Sun Salutations or something
like that to primary nervous system and
that's effectively from Tony Robbins or
many ways to do this called plunge and
so on called shower but to get your body
physiologically into a state where you
can then sit down and have a more
optimistic story for setting strategies
and so on for the day if you're in a
depressed state you're going to see
problems instead of solutions and
ultimately have a really tough time I
think starting your day on the right
note and in the right gear in addition
to that if you want to add extra credit
would suggest that you consider either
journaling which I do almost every
morning with most typically the
five-minute journal which you can look
up with my name you'll find plenty of
details I don't have any business stake
in it or morning pages which we
recommend to me by an exceptionally
successful screenwriter for using
putting words on paper as spiritual
windshield wipers in effect trapping
your monkey mind on paper so you can get
on with your day those are two different
complimentary approaches that you can
explore and experiment with and then you
can look at meditation typically 10 to
20 minutes and using a tool to get
started like headspace a nap the 10 and
10 program is very very helpful and free
to get started with or transmittal
meditation or guided meditations through
say Sam Harris who's a PhD in
neuroscience or Tara brach b ra CH and
some of my friends like maria Popova
prolific entrepreneur and writer has
credited just listening to tara Brock's
2010 smile meditation from the summer as
changing her life and she is absolutely
type-a driven mega productive in her
life so those are a few options and
meditation I would encourage you to
think of as not something very whoo but
instead training for Less emotional
reactivity you're really learning to
observe your thoughts and impulses and
patterns in your own head so that when
something frustrating happens when
someone annoys you when things in
evitable e go sideways during the day
you don't respond in the worst way
possible and make things compulsively
worse alright that's really it you're
able to actually detach say oh I'm
feeling angry I'm about to become angry
and be angry play angry say something
angry and then you can short-circuit
that and choose a better response you
are becoming response able so those are
a few guidelines for experimenting and
then crafting your own morning routines
you